automakers are scrapping engines and
transmissions but electric motors are
still a big bulky burden how do you
shrink them down while making them even
more powerful
i found out by visiting yasa a motor
startup founded by tim walmer a
university of oxford electrical
engineering phd
[Music]
when drivers of future mercedes models
stomp the accelerator of their electric
performance cars they'll get extra oomph
out of the batteries because of
something that sounds straight out of
back to the future
no not flux capacitors but axial flux
motors
these machines are about a factor of 10
more effective when it comes to cooling
than a radial machine so they get 10
times more heat out
which means you can push them harder you
can shrink everything again and that
just has this
cycle of
size down weight down cost down
efficiency up so these are the four kind
of you know mantras we really
really push for
mercedes and even ferrari are turning to
these motors to generate gobs of torque
and blazing 0-60 times
axial flux motors are much smaller than
radio motors the predominant type of
electric motor used by a tesla and other
ev makers
but they pack a more powerful punch
the differences between them has to do
with their orientation and geometry
radial motors are shaped like sausages
with rotating magnetic rotors spinning
within stationary stators
they create flux radially
meaning that it's perpendicular to the
axis of the rotation
flux is what turns the wheels of your
car once you press the accelerator
every time
you hit the accelerator we're putting
hundreds of amps in some cases thousands
of amps of current through these copper
coils as you push current through the
through the copper this this creates an
electromagnet essentially and because we
have magnets on the rotor they create
repulsive and attractive forces which
translate into torque so electric
machine is a torque transducer it
produces torque
that turns into motion
and
torque times speed is power
axial motors are shaped more like
pancakes with the rotor and the stator
made of two discs facing each other
magnetic coils are placed on the face of
the discs
creating a much larger surface area for
the rotor and stator to push against
each other
flux is generated axially meaning that
it's parallel to the axis of rotation
since these motors generate torque at a
much bigger diameter less material is
needed
yasa uses just a few kilograms of iron
for its stators
reducing the mass of the machines by 80
to 85
and obviously we're into a transition
now adopting the technology for pure
electric vehicles where we're scaling up
the technology you know more torque more
power more speed
and also efficiency improvements as well
which are super critical for electric
vehicles there
yasa's motors are the brainchild of tim
walmer within a few years of earning his
doctorate jaguar land rover made plans
to use yasa's motors in the cx-75
a hybrid electric two-seater with enough
horsepower to rival the porsche 918
spyder
mclaren p1 and ferrari's laferrari
while jlr ended up canceling their
project due to financial constraints
yasa's motors found their way into the
koenigsegg regera hybrid hypercar
followed by the ferrari sf90
high-end motors like yasas will be
crucial to brands like amg and ferrari
as they race to electrify the
high-performance vehicles that earn them
prestige and profits
a year ago amg's owner mercedes
announced it would acquire yaasa for an
undisclosed sum
i mean again if you look at the history
of automotive generally
the auto companies wanted to have the
engine you know their core technology
in-house and
and i guess they're seeing
maybe the batteries the motors this is
this is their core technology now so
they um they recognize the importance of
having
long-term differentiation in these
spaces and so they have to bring in a
house
whereas in the age of the internal
combustion engine quicker acceleration
and higher top speeds were achieved with
more engine cylinders
manufacturers will differentiate
performance evs by getting the most out
of batteries with smaller lighter and
more efficient motors
their smaller size could allow car
makers to put one motor on each wheel
which isn't feasible with radial motors
putting a motor on each wheel or at
least one on each axle
would allow for torque vectoring or
controlling how much power motors send
to each individual wheel for improved
agility
high speed cornering might help amg and
ferrari drivers
get over the fact that they're losing
the roar of their 8 10 or 12 cylinder
engines
yasa's motors also could completely
remove the need for a power train on the
so-called skateboard underneath an ev
that would open up more space for
engineers to package batteries
create more room for bigger front and
rear trunks
or allow designers to experiment with
new ideas with respect to aerodynamics
i'm craig trudell and this is how we
move
for more stories like this follow us on
your favorite platforms
[Music]